so you watch snowfall yeah
and franklin's girlfriend gets turned
the [ __ ] out right because she started
smoking crap smoke crack [ __ ] and she
linked up with their other one [ __ ] i
mean everyone girl but
it's the first time in my life i ever
watched something and i thought to
myself crack must be so fire
bro franklin's girlfriend hits the crack
pipe what the [ __ ]
me out of here bro first of all pimping
got into me i didn't get in the pimping
the sauce really chose me and that's
just how i go being back from the bay
when you're shining you look good you
handsome
you're not white
somebody gonna come pay you
somebody it's a [ __ ] out there that
want to pay you she can't wait so did
you have like a bottom [ __ ]
yeah i did on the first rapper on
youtube okay on the first rapper on
twitch
on the first rapper to get signed
straight off the internet from high
school to a record deal to jimmy iveen
the interscope records for over a
million dollars
man
stop playing with me what i'm about to
say i'm 34 bro relax
you that young kid i'm 34. i thought she
was super seasoned how old do you think
i am bro i thought she was like his
oldest taco bell
do i look that old
i don't say you look old thank you well
i appreciate the uh i thought she was a
young looking old dude now you're a old
looking young dude
i'm not sure i've ever felt more
attacked on my show
so the draco the ruler and big draco
collaboration will never happen
i wouldn't oh if he pages
it was awesome being in miami at that
time you know south beach was
was was popping i mean like how much
[ __ ] were you getting at the time in
life like you i mean listen you're in
miami i mean by the way your college had
to be crazy college college was crazy
i'm more of a uh
quality quality over quantity i mean i
love a quantity of quality quantity of
quad
you got wayne over kendrick
hell yeah
really
yeah
bro
wayne yo
this is the thing man it's like and i'm
my thing is kendrick's never missed
wayne's missed a lot
missing is all subjective right
not really but
but wayne's got some black eyes on this
he's got black he does but he's got
glasses but so do tupac you know i got a
lot of a lot of misses
yeah yeah there's a lot which is why
which is why tupac's not in my top he's
he's he's in my top 10-ish but but like
i got um
i kind of put wayne and tupac in the
same tier nah
you put
way better rapper than tupac
he's a way better rapper i don't it is
people that probably send me death
threats for that i don't give a [ __ ]
to see you with that sweat rag bro hey
look look cook's got his sweat rag right
there every fat [ __ ] got a sweat rag no
[ __ ] even if you ain't got in your
pocket in your car or something to dab
that forehead stop playing the games i
know you got it oh god how much love did
you get for the sweat rag a lot no i'm
about to make some [ __ ] no [ __ ] yo
y'all gotta that's gotta be the merch
bruh i gotta be part of my birthday
that's like a fat [ __ ] i was like oh
this guy got the uh the lrg and the
sweat rag he's going up and i was using
that [ __ ] too yeah he was he was patting
himself down
like a [ __ ] it was like a
[ __ ] 94 degree all the hottest
sailboat i was like oh cats coachella
we're doing shrooms
hell yeah and we took the shrooms and
they were really really really really
really really really strong
and
we were both just like laying down in
the grass and [ __ ] like that and it was
cool it wasn't too much but i couldn't
move i didn't want to move and
i think the the deepest and realest
thing that i took away from that was
just the fact that i at one point was
inside of my mother's stomach i was like
wow we were like connected you know what
i mean like so when we were laying down
i'm like we're basically doing the same
thing we're using this the same because
we're the same [ __ ] person i'm like
this is this is deep bro and
you know you're always gonna be cool
with your moms of course but that's
another thing this is right and your mom
for people who don't know like wiz's mom
will be at the functions for sure like
your mom's your mom's a g for sure for
sure so it just yeah it definitely gave
me a cool ass appreciation for for moms
so if you have like lemon pepper like
like cauliflower wings yes i mean this
but that's cauliflower it's not wings
just say you have lemon pepper
cauliflower don't don't say the word
wings but they wing so no they're not
bro i'm gonna keep it a book like
they're called it's cauliflower bro but
look though
what about it as a wing let me ask you
this
how does chicken taste
certainly don't [ __ ] taste like
cauliflower but okay did you see the
meme that they posted on twitter and it
was me and you
and uh adam 22 and vlad uh someone
posted like a meme of all four of our
photos and they said this is hip-hop
media
yo
yo that was [ __ ] hilarious i'll take
you and i being thrown in a category
together because they're actually
legitimate similarities you could point
to right right right right right
where are you and i don't know what
their relationships are so i don't want
to put you in a bad spot but where do
you get to comparing us to adam 22 and
vlad and i get adam 22 and vlad going
together because they get people to say
some semi-incriminating
crazy [ __ ] like i get the whole op thing
but
you and i like two kind of dj nerds
right right
respectful of the music and culture i
just don't that was such to me uh
that was a lazy but very funny hey when
you told your mom
when you told your mom you were
meditating did she laugh at you uh i
i was like when i first like when she
came in and like blew blew me and i
finally whoa okay
no no no no no no wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
no no no no chicago i know i know oh
okay okay you're gonna put me on to this
no no chicago slaying like like like
like me i was like okay she pissed you
off okay okay
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is going on in chicago
damn he just he just switched that [ __ ]
around a lot i caught it i was like no
that don't mean that bro
he said my mom came in my room and blew
me
so if like
if he made you mad you'd be like man you
blew me bro yeah yeah i ain't gonna fly
yeah you just blew me you you making it
like a homo ass wave folks so now i
don't want to say yeah but like hey i'm
just saying
y'all might want to leave that already
like that until you just put it like
that
or you like you just blew me like you
just blew
we did have one interview we had to take
down which one oh uh tiana trump yeah we
did it yeah so we had an interview with
tiana trump that went viral as [ __ ] that
was amazing that [ __ ] was booming on
twitter there's like twitter clips that
got like six million views on that that
was an amazing interview we had this
crazy ass interview with tiana trump and
vicki chase yo i forgot
i still got the clip in my archive and
and right around that time we had like a
ratings meeting with our boss he was
like yo y'all's ratings with females is
in the [ __ ] right now
so then we put out this [ __ ]
interview with these two porn stars
where they're
yo
talking
still got the clip i think the interview
is on pornhub i still got that one clip
in my phone right now it was so many
types of different [ __ ] on my face like
there was like the
like thick that comes and then there was
like the super watery combs and they're
in like the all of it was in my mouth
and [ __ ] and i had a swell like
it was guys
and then but that i don't know if that
was crazy the craziest one i would say
i've done is with
[Music]
we put this on the radio station west
i heart radio's instagram
i remember dj ayo yo what the [ __ ] are
y'all doing over there yo hey i ain't
gonna lie that's one of the moments
where i was like yeah we probably out of
here you know
well it was nice when it lasted yo we
gotta get we that was we shouldn't did
that we should at least bleep that [ __ ]
did we put that on i heart i think i'm
going to china and get a chinese uh
hey
she gonna sign it over to me i'm gonna
be the mother and the father
so you're gonna go to china yeah i wanna
i want a chinese little boy he's not
gonna be miyagi hatch
sick ass bushy fake
give me you've been thinking about this
yeah
man my law you're going over there and
get the
miyagi hatch yeah
so you're gonna go over there and you're
gonna i'm gonna pay for the head
so he's gonna sign it over to me so
you're gonna
artificially inseminate a woman
or are you gonna i'm trying to figure
out how this how this works man i'm
gonna put my sperm in the cup also
okay so you're not even gonna [ __ ] this
girl you're just gonna like yo give it
to the scientists and let them handle
what they got to handle yeah they're
gonna put our stuff together
and then you got miyagi hatch
what's that name bro what is that um it
comes from mr miyagi you know what i'm
saying okay okay i was a karate kid fan
you [ __ ] with uh cobra kai who that is
you said drake's not hip-hop
no no no no and i said listen drake
makes hip-hop music and you said well
drake there's no culture with drake i
think drake makes rap records
okay even pock man i think you know even
papa came out everything stopped
i think all of hip-hop stopped i think
snoopy i know what you think but i'm
telling you
do
was bigger than snoop at his peak
all eyes on me i think they were all
equivalent they're equal you can't say
one's bigger than the other that's what
people do they want to say who's bigger
or there's no bigger
when you heard doggy style everything
stopped for sure
now you're gonna try and tell me when
you heard all eyes on me everything
didn't stop
i think
i think that
yeah i mean obviously all eyes on me is
one of the greatest hip-hop albums ever
when 50 cent came with his album
everything
stopped
that's real
[Music]
that's the peak
when you drop in
stops
that's
the peak
i'm curious man because uh
you and i are similar in age and i know
how much dmx meant to me coming up and
you know he's going through his health
situation and hopefully
you know what what did x mean to you
like
from
he passed
man
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up man
that [ __ ] x man x was a legend man
that dude was like a superhero to me as
a kid man like i always always thought
like you know what i'm saying nobody
could really [ __ ] with x like like no
cap like i always thought like you know
those [ __ ] that are probably like you
know albums and [ __ ] who i might have
liked more and all i said but i'm just
saying like face to face
if the ex pull up on you
you know what i'm saying you're not
[ __ ] with x man uh basically you know
nip been wanting to work with you on
something whatever
like he doesn't know that we're giving
you this so just you know do your thing
and then we're just gonna
basically like you know play it for him
and be like yo you know what i mean yeah
and um
yeah it was nuts bro like i remember
i did this there's way more of that song
that never made it to the song
that part that that uh nip ended up
using throughout the song that was that
was like uh my outro after my verse so
that was like you know that's how like i
kind of ended my verse
and um
but it was it was it was long as [ __ ]
man
it's a long song currently that's what
i'm saying the song is gonna be like
seven minutes and forty five seconds
right all right i never i was never like
damn why why didn't you keep you know i
was just happy to be part of it that
project was a classic to me the first
time i heard it i was like this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is
a masterpiece
people doing whatever to get at people
either way whether it's
songs
catching a [ __ ] with his wife
whatever [ __ ] doing whatever cats
[ __ ] what happened to you right your
girl got shot is that car guys shut up
your car got shot your girl was in the
car right yeah i wasn't in the car she
was driving
did she get hit yeah but she good
she's like again seeing my girl see my
ass but again right like that's
something that under normal
circumstances you would think is
like i you know what i'm saying off
limits if that makes sense yeah but it
seems like what with
what was whatever's going on in
jacksonville [ __ ] is really really yeah
is no like i said there's just no lines
and and i don't know if there's
something to
i don't know man i just i just i would
hate to open my phone
and see your name on academics
and be like you know or see even see
aces name you know what i'm saying like
the end of the day both of y'all came
out the same city
both of you guys are are making money
off this rap [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
i just i don't i just i would i don't
know if there's i mean i don't
understand what people lose their life
is
it's really no
like
there's nothing else to be talked about
but at the same time like you would hope
there would be some sort of resolution
to stop any sort of future
you know situations that might put you
in harm or or anybody else in harm
definitely right you guys were all
dipset like we know that you know what
i'm saying no we know that
and so that's why it just to me like it
is too because they started out as jim
freaky ziki jewels and cam right as the
diplomats
when we came along it was dipset
so when people scream dip said
that's us too
as soon as i'm done with my wife's
amazing mexican food she might cook
i'll eat two bowls of apple jacks
of course
i love apple jacks [ __ ] what's your
favorite what's your favorite cereal
fruity peppers
fruity pebbles rice krispie treats are
fire they get too soggy in the milk
though after a while it's like what am i
eating fruity pebbles that's a hood
classic listen
he just [ __ ] i would eat all [ __ ]
day man it's like it's like and then i'm
like i said apple jacks he's a legend
he living like that
all i know is this kanye highland me bro
we got part two on the laptop ain't
never been seen we'd love for you to
have it it'd be a great personal private
nft
wait wait wait wait wait so there's
another
ray j kim case sex tape
that's that we haven't seen yeah that
was more graphic and better than the
first one we have so much genetics that
we're planning out for a hundred years
so
you know we're doing a really cool [ __ ]
right now where we'll film it and be
like yo
it's 20 21 i'm sitting here
it's like a mexican chocolate i did with
bodhi shout out to bodhisees we're going
to take this i want to drop this in
2080. we're going to put this in tissue
culture this is the flavor profile and
if you work at cookies right now and you
you want to know why we're dropping this
this is why i like it and this is why i
want to name it and we're going to drop
in 2018 and we take that footage and we
put it away so one day maybe it'll be a
hologram or one day it'll be a video
message so maybe nft
something right but point being is i
don't want to open up all these stores
around the world and them have no
purpose or no direction no vision right
like i thought it'd be cool that we have
hundreds of stores around the globe
right
when i'm dead and gone in the future
they see a video of like why we're
releasing this train why he liked it
why he named it what it is and it give
my my employees and my team and whoever
is running them stores [ __ ] vision
bro like have these people fired up what
hats are okay to wear anywhere in l.a i
know there's only a few la hat black
black heads always like black la hat
it's the only one diamondbacks like that
right there uh tampa bay tb uh santana
black yeah i mean
20 bloods yeah i mean
yeah are the arizona diamondbacks
uh avalon anderson's park uh
what did you get in trouble for saying
i'm not gonna say it because i might get
in trouble again
a blip obliviate like obliterate
foxy brown and little kim in the same
room as beyonce and nicki minaj
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he vaccinated man yeah
you want the blank yeah how do i hit the
blunt thing man
i'm not vaccinated
but you tell me that after i hit the
blunt
[ __ ] i don't think about spotify when i
make songs i'm sorry you know what i'm
saying like i i'm i'm pat i was around
before that like i think about the fans
i think about what i want to say i think
about great music yeah because back then
you guys had to figure out how to
monetize everything else what the music
cause you were driving you should die
tomorrow i would not give a [ __ ] you
feel me like i would still do my thing i
would still figure it out i would still
make a way just like i did before that's
all they result of trying to be in the
music business like i'm in the middle of
an interview right now bro
i got you i got you
hey this is my producer he ain't sending
me the folder hey hey cook what the [ __ ]
are we doing
right now
the weirdest thing you've jerked off to
this month
or this year
oh man dude
i don't know
probably a picture of your cousin
[Laughter]
[Music]
so i went to parole he asked for the
urine i pressed the button
[ __ ] came out like applesauce
i was like oh [ __ ] he said yo
you tested it put the little strip in it
he said yo
it's clean but i need you to go straight
to the hospital when you get the [ __ ]
out of here because something's not
right i was like sorry sir i just don't
drink a lot of water i'm going straight
to the hospital whatever the case you
know what i'm saying
and that he let me go and i was like
thank god empty that [ __ ] out put some
forgot some clean put in there but you
know that [ __ ] was crazy even me i was
like what the [ __ ] is that wait so you
you [ __ ] came my lumpy ass [ __ ] was hard
like he was like sir
you got cancer yeah
you got something going on with your
blood you should have
go to the hospital
if it's coming why fear it embrace it
monetize oh god that was crazy
big paws
big cost alerts
big paws alerts i got
oh [ __ ] did you invent paws yes wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute i did
not know this i am the inventor you were
the inventor of paws my crew the best
out we invented pause for sure
because nobody could ever ever say that
i didn't no that's all of us that came
from my block
period my crew best out yeah that's what
i like about him yeah a horny dude and
he'll keep it right you wanna know the
coincidence look at the skin
pigmentation y'all [ __ ] he's not
white for the record though he's half if
you're going to put him and his whole
history of his people in the same bucket
as mine from a totally different part of
the world that just proves how arbitrary
these racial labels are well what's your
ass
to know white [ __ ] tell me what a white
[Music]
[Laughter]
he said [ __ ]
oh that was great i'm a white man bro
that's what i said why do you think that
you're not going to say you don't [ __ ]
with your cousin
you know what i'm saying i don't [ __ ]
with some of my cousins but yeah like
it's like bro it's like we failed like
i'll be like why am i going to distance
myself from you maybe your cousin's a
mega person
jesus christ that's when you might just
yourself i'm just saying well they're
still your cousin yeah but like yeah
like we're still friends on facebook you
know what i mean but like
you might have to dizzy yourself that's
like god
jesus christ who would you consider to
be the cp3 of rap
the cp3 of rap somebody who's like maybe
doesn't get that acknowledgement but
it's like an all-time great what they do
you know what i'm saying
he 40. you do you make the bae he 40. he
make the big jump for real
yeah that's hard i like that that's not
a bad one e40
you i'll let you have that man i let you
have that yeah yeah i'll let you have
that bay area over there oh by the way
nico blitz is here who you
you guys competed against each other in
high school yeah so yeah when i was in
high school i used to uh horrible
i used to date filipino women and nico
actually stole my girl yeah you know his
girl yeah i assure you you have the
bigger dicks
25 push-ups and you got to do them live
on ig all right i'm done we'll go we're
going live with each other but but
they're on call though
we're on call what's that mean on call
memes i could call you up at any time
any day and you got to go on live and do
a push-up and you got to do if i say got
to give me five you got to go live
without i'm familiar with the style of
all right and vice versa vice versa 25
push-ups and if the sun's wind he's got
to put his son's jersey on if not i got
to put on one of your suits exactly
please make sure it's washed but when
you guys got the news that katie was
joining the warriors what was that group
chat like
[Music]
listening
that's how i was bro just like because
you know you're gonna have to see them
in the finals i'm like for what that's
what that's all we all looking like huh
then we like well what russ got to say
about that's what we all what russ
wouldn't say about this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is crazy
no he didn't it wasn't katie it was
braun first going to miami broad knows
he wrote basketball okay let me ask you
this do you think that was i always look
at the friends i'll ruin basketball give
me the back story on how mike tyson
ended up on second round knockout oh man
you know what i'm saying like if you
want to talk about sucker my knockout
again
then we could easily focus on i don't
want to talk about the beef i just want
to talk about it
how did mike tyson end up on the second
round knockout no no i mean listen this
is mike second round one more time just
say it
second round